hey you guys flickers of fear time once
again and we're still doing monster
march
this is another movie that was
recommended by one of you guys in one of
our side tracks live stream uh the live
chat
and this is another one that somehow
kind of like went under my radar
and
i feel like it went under a lot of
people's radar because it really didn't
do all that well it came out in 2016
and uh
it's kind of a shame because
i uh i really really liked this a lot
but i can see how
some people might not because it is
a genre bending type of film and it's
something
i you know it's weird like the concept
of it is very weird but if you like get
into the concept i think it's like
really really entertaining and i don't
really think i've seen anything quite
like this before like any kind of genre
mashup like this
so as i mentioned this came out in 2016
and it's called colossal
now i will say it's probably better
i only knew i had not i did not watch
the trailer um pretty much all i knew
about this movie going into it was just
like a one sentence
summary
uh of the plot
which so i kind of knew what was coming
but
i think this is one of those movies that
is way better if you don't really know
where it's going if you don't want the
whole thing spoiled for you then i would
recommend like not watching this i know
i say this a lot but i just think it's
better not really knowing where it's uh
going at all now i will say though it's
not exactly
a horror movie it's not i don't even
know what i would call it it's
definitely a mashup of
sci-fi
fantasy action with
like indie
drama comedy or maybe like a black
comedy so it's a very very unusual
combination and i think in the wrong
hands this could have gone terribly
terribly wrong
but
i mean i think it's a credit to the
director and the actors involved that
this works as well as it uh does and
that it was successful as was at least
from my point of view because like i
said i really really liked it a lot
so this was directed by nacho vigolando
uh who probably best known for doing
time crimes uh he also did uh probably
like the best segment in i think it was
a vhs viral it was one of the vhs movies
anyway uh he also did open windows if
any of you have seen that which was kind
of like done entirely on a computer not
a bad flick at all uh and he also did
puka
the christmas movie that was on hulu
that we uh reviewed it's in part of the
into the dark series i did puka and uh
the sequel as well uh so he directed
that to you so
he's a spanish director
and uh he's i guess his stuff is usually
i've seen a couple of them i haven't
seen time crimes yet even though a lot
of people have told me that i should
because it's like a really good sci-fi i
have seen open windows and i have seen
puka and i have seen a vhs
movie that had his segment in it so i
have seen like a good uh you know thing
of his stuff but
i like i said i kind of feel like
had had a director like him not been at
the helm of this i don't know if it
would have worked as well but
thankfully he was involved so
uh this also has anne hathaway in it and
apparently see i didn't even know this
because i don't follow
uh you know i really i like movies i
mostly you know follow horror movies and
stuff like that so i don't really know
what's going on in like the bigger wider
like movie world entertainment world
generally like sometimes i'll go see
stuff but i don't usually read a lot of
stuff i'm not like real into like
celebrity gossip or behind the scenes
kind of [ __ ]
so i didn't realize that
uh anne hathaway i guess it had
something of maybe a backlash i'm not in
terms of sure entirely why maybe she was
just in too much stuff or people were
over her or whatever i don't know but uh
i didn't even know that until like i
started like researching this movie
but uh so yeah so i guess she'd been in
some stuff i've seen her in a few things
she's fine
and
she was kind of like i guess the role
she was getting she wasn't like super
happy about so she said i want to do
something like weird or something
different and when she was sent this
script she was super excited about it
and honestly it was kind of her star
power that ended up getting this movie
i don't know if it ended up getting it
made but it certainly didn't hurt you
know what i mean because she was quite
famous so she like signed on immediately
she compared this a bit to being john
malkovich
which
it's kind of like that i don't want to
say i don't want to lean too far in that
direction because people might get the
wrong idea uh i've also seen it called
godzilla meets lost in translation which
is more accurate in my opinion uh so
yeah but we'll get into that so so her
being in this she's kind of playing i
guess she's sort of played this kind of
character for i kind of feel like
like i said i haven't seen her on a ton
of stuff but everything that i've seen
her in she's usually some kind of like
maybe like little awkward quirky like
manic pixie dream girl type character in
this one though she's actually
pretty great she plays kind of like a
hot mess
alcoholic uh sort of character and uh
she pretty much kills it
also uh jason sudeikis is in this and
i've seen him in a few times uh in a few
things and i feel like he usually plays
you know kind of like the affable every
man like nice dude type of character and
he kind of subverts that a little bit in
this role and he's
fantastic he's really really good in
this so uh you know like i said i
haven't seen him in a ton of stuff but
he just like he really impressed me in
this movie
so
let's get into like i said this is
better if you don't know where it's it's
not a horror movie it is a monster movie
there are monsters in it it's a kaiju
movie but
it's like a cross between a kaiju movie
and like an indie
black comedy i don't want to sell too
much of the comedy it is funny
but i see a lot of things calling it
comedy and i don't know if i'd call it
that like maybe dramedy is more
or maybe black comedy i don't know
because it does like get darker and
darker toward the end and honestly like
some of the some of the plot twists or
some of the twists that the plot took
like as it went on actually really
surprised me i didn't really know
where it was going which i thought was
really good because you can kind of
that's another thing this this movie
does too it almost takes like some kind
of tropes of
these kind of like indie type movies or
rom-coms
and sort of set some stuff up like that
and then kind of like subverts them like
in a really unexpected way and i think
it does that really well uh so there's
that as well like i said i'm not really
even sure what genre i would call this
it's it's crazy
so here's the setup
so in hathaway plays this woman
who
uh she lives in new york with her
boyfriend and she's apparently a a
writer you know she writes for some uh
kind of like vlog or whatever it's
something like that and she's kind of uh
well-known as far as that goes but uh
she's been out of work for a little
while presumably because she's a little
bit of an alcoholic so you're led to
assume that some kind of like incident
took place
at work and she kind of got fired so
she's been out of work for a little
while uh and has kind of been out
drinking with all her friends and stuff
and at the very beginning of the movie
uh basically her boyfriend comes in and
says look i can't deal with you anymore
uh you need to get your [ __ ] together um
you know he's like i love you but this
is not working out so he kicks her out
of their apartment
now she is uh broke because like i said
she has no job and now she has no house
so she doesn't really have much choice
but to move back to her old kind of very
small you know very working-class
hometown which called main head and she
goes there and uh stays in her parents
old house which i guess is empty they
live somewhere else i'm presuming and uh
you know no one's running it out so they
let her stay there
so she goes back to the town and uh she
by chance or you know like i said it's a
very small town she runs into a
childhood friend of hers named oscar
and he is very very excited to see her
and he turns out he has never got out of
uh the town
and he uh his parents had owned a bar
and his parents died so he inherited the
bar so that's what he's been doing this
whole entire time
and so he um you know he's like i said
he's really happy to see her they
haven't spoken in a very long time he's
kind of been following her career a
little bit you know since she went to
new york and he's always kind of like oh
you know i always admired you for
getting the hell out of here you were
the only you know person that did that
and it's so cool that you're back and so
uh it happens that he is able to give
her a part-time job at the bar probably
not the best situation since she's an
alcoholic and uh you know tends to like
black out or do crazy uh irresponsible
[ __ ] when she's really drunk uh but yeah
so she has she gets a part-time job and
he also starts to do
seemingly very nice things for her other
than that like oh i'll bring you some
furniture like we have all this old
furniture at my uncle's house and he
like furnishes her house and like brings
her a tv and all this other kind of
stuff so after this initial setup then
the weird [ __ ] starts
so it turns out that one day she's kind
of like been out of the bars like it's
her first night at work at the bar and
she's hanging out with oscar and like
these two other guys that kind of work
there or hang out there she gets like
super blotto drunk and blacks out for
like nine hours and doesn't remember
anything
when she wakes up she sees like her
sister calls her and it's like have you
seen this crazy [ __ ] on the news
so what's on the news is seoul south
korea is being terrorized by a gigantic
monster a kaiju
and it kind of looks like it doesn't
really it doesn't look like godzilla it
kind of looks like i'm not even sure
what it looks like it kind of looks like
groot i don't know it's it kind of looks
like a turtley it's reptilian but it has
kind of like a weird it's hard to
describe but yeah so so there's a big
monster
and it's
kind of stomping all around uh seoul
korea uh south korea and is killing
people and destroying buildings and
whatnot
so
you know obviously everybody's at first
it's like oh it's got to be a hoax but
then obviously like it's really not a
hoax and everybody's like holy [ __ ] like
giant monsters exist this is the
craziest [ __ ] ever like the entire world
is different now you know so there's all
this thing where
everybody in the world is like holy crap
and we have to send money to south korea
and everything and then through a series
of uh circumstances
it comes to pass that anne hathaway's
character
realizes
that
her actions
directly cause
the actions of the kaiju in
in other words uh whatever she does over
here in maine head which i'm assuming is
upstate new york i'm not i don't think
they even say like where it's at
but
uh anything she does
well it's not anything it there's like
all these parameters which i'll get into
in a minute but uh within certain
limitations and parameters things that
she does in this town that's what the
monster does in seoul south korea so her
actions here are controlling this giant
monster that's actually like killing
people and destroying property like on
the other side of the world
what the parameters are
and they kind of get into why this is
later on i mean you can't get too much
of will that wouldn't happen well
obviously i mean you know what i mean
it's like you just gotta roll with it
it's magical realism uh and there is
like actually
a reason why it's this one particular
place but there's this one little park
like a little playground
and she has to be like this particular
playground is mapped almost exactly to
this one area in seoul south korea so
whenever she steps into this particular
playground at a particular time of day
whatever she does within that playground
that's what the monster will do in seoul
so if she swings her arm around it'll
hit a building and [ __ ] like that so
there's that kind of thing like i said
don't think too hard about it it's i
know it sounds like a crazy premise and
that's what i'm saying
on paper
on paper this sounds like what the [ __ ]
like what the [ __ ] did i just watch but
if you're watching it like it absolutely
works and like i said the balance of it
it's just crazy that you could take like
a genre mashup like this and actually
make it work because it sounds
ridiculous but it actually does it
actually does work
so uh so yeah so she discovers that her
you know that her actions cause you know
this monster to do it what it's doing
and then obviously she starts feeling
terrible because in you know in her
drunken stupor when she's been like
stumbling through this you know
playground on her way home she's
presumably killed like hundreds or maybe
thousands of people on the other side of
the world and she starts feeling really
[ __ ] guilty about it
so she starts to think maybe she needs
to kind of like get her [ __ ] together
not drink as much whatever
and then it comes to pass that oscar uh
you know her friend who owns the bar who
is also
i don't want to say he's in love with
her because it's not exactly that
because his character is kind of a lot
more uh sinister than that as it goes on
which like i said kind of surprised me
in the end and i kind of i was like oh
it's going there all right and uh i kind
of liked that it did that because like i
said it's kind of it's kind of ballsy
it's not a comedy it is funny like
toward the beginning but it just kind of
gets darker dark and it goes pretty
[ __ ] up places toward the end but it
turns out that our friend oscar
he discovers that when he goes into the
playground he becomes a giant robot in
seoul south korea
so they kind of start at first they're a
little bit at odds with each other so
they kind of start fighting
and so that's so it translates to the
kaiju like fighting over in korea
and uh so as the movie goes on i don't i
don't know i know i said that it's like
uh that you shouldn't know anything
about it like going in but now that i'm
kind of at this point i'm just like i
don't really know if i want to
necessarily spoil where it goes because
i feel like a lot of people maybe didn't
see this like i said it came out of
2016.
i think it only cost like 15 million to
make uh you know and you know you can
tell it's lower budget because a lot of
it is kind of like you know like an
indie
drama comedy black comedy type of thing
and then most of the monster action is
like on people's tvs and stuff you know
what i'm saying like you don't because
they're you know the all the people like
watching the monster action are in the
united states whereas the monsters are
rampaging in korea somebody's like
seeing it on their phones or their
tablets or the tv or whatever so which i
think was a really good idea because you
could keep the
cg to like to a minimum and you know
make it look better so you have that
going on but it's kind of like so this
only cost 15 million to make and i think
it made like less than 5 million back it
seemed like it just came and went i can
see why because i think i mean i love
like i said i love a good genre mashup i
love weird [ __ ] i love
a movie that's just like it's like yeah
we're gonna do like an indie drama with
like about alcoholism and
uh domestic abuse
or like emotional manipulation
and we're gonna make and we're gonna do
it with kaiju in it and you know what i
mean and i just i love the uh the
audacity of that but i know a lot of
people don't a lot of it's it's not like
a straightforward
you know it is a what the [ __ ] that i
just watched kind of movie but in kind
of like the best possible way
but so yeah i will say obviously
this is another you know there have been
other movies before that where like the
monster was a metaphor for something and
in this one uh you know obviously the
monster is you know a metaphor for her
not just her alcoholism but also her
kind of
uh her lack of
power over her own life her lack of
self-esteem her kind of like self-hatred
in a way so it's kind of like something
she has to battle even though the
monster is real and it does actually
have effects on people and so i kind of
think that
that's like i said that's kind of where
the metaphor comes from of her being
this monster and like destroying
you know other people without meaning to
so there's that but to the movie's
credit it knows that the metaphor is
very on the nose
so there's a lot of other stuff going on
too like i really i liked like all the
monster [ __ ] is cool like don't go into
this thinking that it's gonna be like
wall-to-wall like kaiju action because
it's not um you know you do get a couple
little monster destruction things but
it's mostly like i said on screens like
you're seeing it on the news or whatever
this is mostly like um
like kind of a thing between
mostly between her and oscar like how
their relationship develops and how the
how their own like kind of monsters or
demons like the fight with one another
and i'm making it sound like
when i said that out loud i was kind of
like people were probably just like oh
jesus christ and we're like rolling
their eyes and stuff it's not like it's
not pretentious i did not find it
pretentious at all even though as i said
the central metaphor is very
obvious but
that's okay like the movie knows that
and like rolls with it and
it's it still works you know what i mean
and it's still really entertaining i
really liked all the character stuff
like i said jason sudeikis i mean anne
hathaway is great in this too she's
pretty good like you know she's pretty
awesome like playing a hot mess this
might be the first thing that i've seen
her in where she played
a character this [ __ ] up or a
character that's damaged but she's still
sympathetic
jason sudeikis like i said i've seen him
in a couple of things and he usually
plays you know like a nice dude so i
kind of like that in this they they sort
of like subverted that a little bit like
he does start out playing you know his
regular kind of like hey i'm a nice guy
character and i'm gonna help you out and
all this other stuff and then it just
gets darker and darker and darker and it
was kind of scary because
you know we've all known people like
that um that put on this like veneer of
being this really nice super helpful
person but when [ __ ] doesn't go the way
they want it to
then suddenly
the mask comes off and you know now
they're a monster essentially so i
really like that it went there and like
i said this went like way darker than i
was expecting to it's not i don't want
to say it's not like a giant bummer it's
really really hard to explain it's hard
to explain like the tone of this movie
because it's like funny but
really dark and then it's like has
monsters but it's i don't know it's like
it's really it's it struck a balance
like really really well
so like i said i don't think i've ever
seen i've seen some weird-ass movies in
my time with some weird-ass concepts
this probably isn't the weirdest concept
i've ever heard of for a movie or that
i've ever seen in a movie but
i don't know this is it's a really
original take on
not just like an indie film like a
metaphorical film about like addiction
and you know domestic abuse and things
like that but
also
this kind of
i don't know just this kind of like also
it's kind of like a fun
monster maybe like with comedic elements
in it too and like i said that seems
like it would be really really difficult
to pull off but
uh props to nacho vigolando for
for [ __ ] going there and like i said
[ __ ] i i will always respect a
filmmaker that will make something weird
like this knowing that it's probably not
gonna do very well or it's not going to
connect with a lot of audiences because
it's just too bizarre so that's i have a
lot more respect for filmmakers that do
that that just oh we're going to like
make this big crowd-pleasing
movie that's fine but everybody will
forget about it in a little while i
don't think i'm going to be forgetting
this movie anytime soon um i really had
a good time with it and i just i thought
it was pretty [ __ ] great so if you
want to watch it uh it's on hulu at the
moment my it's probably some other
places too but i watched it on hulu uh
and like i said i think was it i think
it might have been tila that recommended
this but i could be wrong about that
like so if one of y'all is watching it
like tell me
watching this like tell me who it was
that recommended it because this is
another one that just
kind of passed me by and uh and that's
kind of a shame so i'm glad that i have
some of you guys out there to like
recommend some movies to me because
there's so many out there that uh that i
can't keep track of all of them so uh if
it wasn't tila then whoever it was like
thank you very much for recommending
this because i really really dug this a
great deal so as i said it's on hulu if
you want to watch it and that will do it
for this installment of flickers of fear
continuing on with monster march and i
will see you guys on the next one
bye